Diese Phänomene auf dem Mond sind wirklich
äußerst mysteriös: Immer wieder mal flackern
rätselhafte Lichterscheinungen und kurze
Lichtblitze an der Mondoberfläche auf. Und
zwar mehrmals in der Woche - und das seit
Jahren! Forschungsteams weltweit sind diesem
Rätsel schon seit langer Zeit auf der Spur.
Ein Forschungsteam aus Würzburg hat jetzt
ein neues Teleskop an den Start gebracht,
um dieses Phänomen endlich aufzuklären.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - abonniert den
Kanal, denn hier gibt es täglich spannende
Science-Videos. Herzlich willkommen!
Die mysteriösen Leucht-Phänomene auf dem
Mond rauben Astronomie-Teams weltweit den
Schlaf. Und das schon seit den 1950-er Jahren,
als man sie das erste mal beobachtet hatte.
Doch auch heute noch gibt es keine eindeutige
Erklärung, da langfristige und systematische
Beobachtungen fehlen. Dafür unglaublich viele
Spekulationen: Werden diese Leuchterscheinungen
etwa ausgelöst durch lunare Meteoriteneinschläge?
Ein kurzzeitiges Aufleuchten könnte durchaus
durch den Aufprall eines Meteors verursacht
werden. Oder stecken etwa Wechselwirkungen
des Sonnenwindes mit dem Mond-Regolith dahinter?!
Schließlich reagieren die elektrisch geladenen
Teilchen des Sonnennwindes mit den Mondstaub-Partikeln...
Der Raumfahrttechniker Hakan Kayal von der
Universität Würzburg hat noch eine weitere
mögliche Erklärung am Start: “Auf dem
Mond wurden auch seismische Aktivitäten beobachtet.
Bei Bewegungen der Oberfläche könnten aus
dem Mondinneren Gase austreten, die das Sonnenlicht
reflektieren. Das würde die Leuchterscheinungen
erklären, die teils über Stunden anhalten”.Hakan
Kayal ist eifrig bei der Sache und höchst
motiviert. Und so hat er zusammen mit seinem
Team ein eigenes Mondteleskop gebaut und im
April in einem privaten Observatorium in Spanien
in Betrieb genommen. Hier sind die Wetterbedingungen
um Längen besser als in Deutschland, um den
Mond ins Visier zu nehmen. Für die Experten
und Expertinnen ist die große Entfernung
von Würzburg nach Spanien aber kein Problem,
denn das Teleskop wird aus Würzburg ferngesteuert.
Insgesamt zwei Kameras haben den Mond fortlaufend
im Blick. Wenn beide ein Leuchten registrieren,
werden Fotos und Videos gemacht. Das ist ja
inzwischen so möglich, dass auch im Nachinein
ab dem Moemnt vor dem Ereignis eine Aufnahme
abgespeichert werden kann. Diese werden dann
nach Würzburg geschickt, um von den Fachleuten
ausgewertet zu werden. Wenn diese dann feststellen,
das es tatsächlich eine Leuchterscheinung
dokumentiert werden konnte, werden die entsprechenden
Daten mit Daten der Europäischen Raumfahrtagentur
ESA verglichen. Wenn auch dort entsprechende
Phänomene registriert werden konnten, soll
dahingehend weitere intensive Forschung betrieben
werden. Derzeit ist das Teleskop aus Würzburg
durch alles was so zwischen dem Mond und dem
Teleskop passiert noch etwas fehleranfällig,
aber genau daran wird gearbeitet. Der Plan
sieht vor, Künstliche Intelligenz zu nutzen.
So könnte das System selbst lernen, Unterscheidungen
zu treffen. Und zwar zwischen wichtigen Ereignissen
- wie eben den Mondblitzen - und unwichtigen
Ereignissen - wie beispielsweise dem Vorbeiflug
eines Vogels an der Kamera. Schon im kommenden
Jahr sollen neuronale Netzwerke diese Arbeit
übernehmen. Langfristig gesehen hat das Team
um Kayal aber noch größere Ziele: Das System
soll schon bald auf einer Satelliten-Mission
eingesetzt werden. Die Kameras könnten dann
ohne die Störungen, die sich durch die Atmosphäre
ergeben, im störungsfreier arbeiten. Vor
allem in Hinblick auf zukünftige bemannte
Mondmissionen ist die Klärung dieses lunaren
Rätsels wirklich erstrebenswert. Dazu Hakan
Kayal: “Wer irgendwann eine Mondbasis bauen
will, muss die Gegebenheiten vor Ort natürlich
bestens kennen“. Und nicht nur das US-amerikanische
Raumfahrtunternehmen SpaceX von Elon Musk,
sondern beispielsweise auch China sehen den
Mond als einen möglichen neuen Lebensraum
für uns Menschen. Somit ist auch die Rückkehr
von Astronauten zum Mond fest geplant. Bereits
im Jahr 2024 soll eine bemannte US-Raumsonde
auf dem Mond landen. Aber auch die ESA möchste
eine Mondbasis errichten und auch Indien zeigt
großes Interesse - wenn auch zunächst nur
mit unbemannten Sonden. Der Wettlauf zum Mond
hat also längst begonnen. Warum die Mondlandung
Kein Fake war. Anklicken, anschauen und tut
Tim von Astro Comics TV einen dicken Gefallen.
Abonniert seinen Kanal heute. Er braucht nur
noch ein paar Abos bis 10.000. ICH DENKE ER
WIRD SICH TIERISCH ÜBER DIE ÜBERASHUNG FREUEN!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!